in the United States we waste about 62
million tons of food every year and one
in seven or about 40 million Americans
don't have enough food in Pittsburgh we
are starting to take a crack at this big
problem the forint of food rescue works
with food retailers who have surplus
food and what we do is we collect that
surplus food every day and match it to
nonprofits that serve people who are
hungry and this food is transported by
volunteers that we call food rescue
heroes who are mobilized for an app when
our food rescue heroes rescue food they
take it from a retailer such as Giant
Eagle and it may be five boxes of fruits
and vegetables and bread and they bring
it to an agency that serves people in
poverty or who are food insecure and
that agency distributes it that same day
everyone knows about food waste food
donors have been aware of this for years
they just haven't had a way to prevent
it or redirect it so once they find out
that or they found out that you know we
will take their surplus food and feed
people who are food insecure they all
say yes I work as entrepreneur in
residence at the block Center and what
I'm hoping to do is impart to other
students who want to be entrepreneurs
social entrepreneurs and give them tools
and things that I've learned to help
them take their ideas off the ground
this is our highest season where we need
the most food rescue heroes and it's
also a season where it's even more
meaningful because you know you we all
have the opportunity to celebrate with
friends and family with lots of food
well let's give that opportunity as well
to everyone